america's first newspaper started
publishing long before the nation had
even been born
the first was printed in boston starting
in 1690.
but in the centuries since we've come to
rely on the daily edition of our
favorite paper
in one entire u.s state though that
tradition is about to come
to an end major garrett has the story
for more than 100 years the casper star
tribune has served the state of wyoming
john bailey a doctor in casper has
subscribed for
decades we've taken a paper for probably
55 or 60 years
and i've always read the paper as a way
i think to get
local news the news that's important
within the community which
may be the most important news there is
and they've walked with our community
through the ups and the downs and the
booms and the bus
brooke kaufman who once worked for the
paper heads
visit casper and the convention bureau
so i feel like having them as a partner
and somebody that's really foundational
in our community
has made a difference and it is critical
and i think it's a news outlet that
keeps us informed about what's going on
in our backyard
starting this month the star tribune
will cut the number of days it prints
the paper from seven to five
this continues a downsizing trend in
2008 the paper had 40 reporters and six
bureaus now it has 13 reporters and
one bureau wyoming is a big place and
the paper is receding from towns like
lost springs population four
brad reese farms there so out here
in rural wyoming you still like
traditions you still like sitting down
with your family to meals
and so that tradition of a newspaper
coming that you can sit down and open
i think that's something that we're
going to miss it kind of hurts to lose
that
the monday and tuesday editions will
only be available
online and when that happens wyoming
will become the only state in the nation
without a daily
printed newspaper for brad reese
holding a newspaper is different and
better
i'm tired of getting on the internet you
know what i mean i'm tired of computers
i don't want to look at a computer
anymore
i just want to live my life and go enjoy
it and sometimes that just means sitting
down with a nice drink and a
newspaper to read you know one of my
first thoughts when i heard the news was
you know how many of our older readers
are suddenly gonna you know go out
spend 400 on an ipad to read the e
edition
nick reynolds is the star tribune's
state house reporter
you know we adapt to things all the time
but if we just think about how long
print has been around and how
steady of a presence it's been i mean
we're talking centuries here and you
know this is like the greatest
disruption to one of the most consistent
mediums
um in human history penelope abernathy
researches the decline of newspapers and
the rise of digital media at the
university of north carolina school of
journalism
cutting back on the printing and
distribution of a newspaper on certain
days makes a lot of economic sense
for newspapers what it often doesn't
take into account
is the dependence that people in
outlying areas
that do not have access to digital
alternatives
wyoming ranks near the bottom nationally
in internet access
meaning on days it does not print a
paper the star tribune's local and
regional news coverage will be invisible
in one fifth of the state and what does
a local community lose
when this type of community journalism
disappears
you typically lose the person who shows
up at the school board meeting
when you have a pullback in both
coverage and circulation
of a state and regional paper what you
typically lose is coverage of the major
issues in both the region and the state
we depend on the state and regional
newspapers
to kind of bring it all together for us
and help us understand what the truly
important issues are in wyoming a
six-hour commute
is not uncommon knitting the state
together is a role the star tribune
played
in print every single day now some news
there
as it has been in other parts of rural
america
will fall through the cracks in the
internet
for cbs this morning saturday major
garrett
washington because of poor internet
access so a fifth of readers then
wouldn't have access to that and i know
it's a silly thing but yeah for some
people it is
that's access but the silly thing to me
is sometimes you do just want to hold
that paper
yeah you heard one of the men in there
all right
have a drink read the paper yeah exactly
all right